bonjour à tous cet après midi les
sénateurs examinent le quatrième projet
de loi de finances rectificative pour
2010 dans ce projet de loi le déficit
est finalement légèrement inférieure à
ce qui était initialement prévu
puissent ils passent de 152 milliards
d'euros à 148 milliards soit 100 milles
néanmoins cette baisse est avant tout
due à des recettes non fiscales
exceptionnelles provenant par exemple de
la caisse des dépôts et consignations
ainsi pour président de la commission
des finances jean arthuis
tout comme pour l'opposition le
gouvernement peine à maîtriser ses
dépenses publiques notamment ses
dépenses sociales ou bien encore ses
dépenses de personnel surtout
l'opposition s'inquiètent actuellement
la crise financière qui traverse
l'europe et notamment de l'aide que la
france va apporter à l'irlande tout de
suite donc direction l'hémicycle très
bonne séance
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet de loi de finances rectificative
pour 2010 dans la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur françois baroin
ministre du budget des comptes publics
de la fonction publique et de la réforme
de l'état porte-parole du gouvernement
ce président monsieur le rapporteur
général mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs j'ai l'honneur de vous
présenter aujourd'hui le traditionnel
projet de loi de finances rectificative
de fin d'année
il s'agit du quatrième collectif pour
l'année 2010 les précédents étant celle
de ceux du 9 mars de cette année
relatifs aux investissements d'avenir du
7 mai sur l'aide à la grèce et du 7 juin
sur la mise en place du fonds de
stabilisation de solidarité européenne
ce projet de loi de finances
rectificative procède à un certain
nombre d'ajustements concernant
l'équilibré du budget de l'état ces
ajustements de prendre acte du respect
nos objectifs en matière de dépense et
nos prévisions de recettes sur
lesquelles je ne reviens pas cette année
la norme de dépense est respectée le
solde budgétaire marque une légère
amélioration depuis nos dernières
prévisions
nous avons respecté la norme de dépense
et les dépenses évolueront bien selon la
norme de zéro volume fixé pour cette
année 2010
notre engagement de maîtrise des
dépenses est confirmée nous respectons
le plafond de dépenses fixé à 3 152
milliards et 300 millions d'euros
l'évolution favorable de la charge des
intérêts de la dette permet de compenser
les besoins accrus pour les politiques
de l'emploi et de la solidarité
de même les recettes 2010 sont en ligne
avec les dernières prévisions que nous
avons exposé dans le cadre des projets
de loi de finances pour l'année
prochaine dans les recettes fiscales qui
s'élèveront à 255 milliards d'euros que
les recettes non fiscales
en conséquence le déficit budgétaire est
globalement conforme à nos prévisions
est même en légère amélioration
puisqu'il s'établit à 149 milliards et
700 millions d'euros en exécution contre
152 milliards prévus dans la dernière
loi de finances rectificative
ceci est essentiellement le fait de la
réévaluation du coût pour l'état de la
réforme de la taxe professionnelle pour
cette année sans incidence sur le coût
de cette réforme en rythme de croisière
ce projet de loi de finances
rectificative permettent aussi d'apurer
les dettes de l'état vis-à-vis de la
sécurité sociale
clarifiant de cette façon la relation
financière un effort important a déjà
été réalisée puisque cette dette
s'élevait à 7 milliards à la fin de
l'année 2006 la mobilisation des
excédents du panier de recettes
affectées à la sécu en compensation les
allégements généraux de charges à
hauteur d'un milliard 4 permet d'apurer
le montant résiduel de date constaté à
fin 2009 et à partir du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
l'année prochaine
le passage un régime le panier
définitivement affectés à la sécurité
sociale s'effectue donc sur des bases
assainies
c'est un point important sur lequel le
gouvernement a porté une attention
soutenue
nous avons entendu par ailleurs l'appel
des départements en difficulté
financière
dans la lignée du rapport jamet nous
souhaitons leur apporter une solution
pragmatique pour la construction de
leurs budgets 2010 et 2011 le
gouvernement a décidé la mise en place
d'un mécanisme exceptionnel de soutien
aux départements en difficulté doté de
150 millions d'euros financée par
redéploiement à partir de la caisse
nationale de solidarité pour l'autonomie
et du fonds national des solidarités
actives
nous avons bien évidemment calibrer ces
redéploiements de façon à ne pas
déséquilibrer les actions menées par ces
deux organismes
premièrement nous créons un fonds de
soutien aux départements en difficulté à
hauteur de 75 millions d'euros gérés par
la cns a pour le compte de l'état
précisément face au poids croissant et
ce n'est pas à la haute assemblée
je vais dire les difficultés d'un
certain nombre de départements
face au poids croissant disait 'je de
l'allocation personnalisée pour
l'autonomie
il s'agit d'apporter une aide
exceptionnelle aux départements les plus
exposés à la dépense de l'apa sur la
base de critères objectifs
les crédits du fonds de soutien seront
répartis entre les départements les plus
exposés en fonction de trois critères me
semble-t-il exhaustif et acceptable par
touches d'une part la part des personnes
âgées de plus de 75 ans
deuxièmement le rapport entre le revenu
moyen par habitant de l'ensemble des
départements et le revenu par habitant
de chaque département le revenu prises
en considération et le dernier revenu
imposable connu et enfin le potentiel
fiscal des départements genevois
personne de sérieux susceptibles de
contester objectivement ces critères eux
mêmes objectifs
nous compléterons cette aide par une
enveloppe de soutien conventionnelle
d'un monte
de 75 millions d'euros qui seront
engagées par la mobilisation de crédits
non versés au fonds national des
solidarités actives en raison d'une
montée en charge de revenu de solidarité
active activités plus lente que celle
initialement prévue
il était nous semble utile nécessaire de
répondre de façon immédiate et
opérationnel à la préoccupation actuelle
de nombreux élus concernant certains
départements en difficulté mais cet
effort exceptionnel devrait être suivie
d'une action plus structurelle face à
les crédits sont bien connus entre les
recettes et les dépenses des
départements il est indispensable de
rationaliser d'une part l'action des
départements comme le suggère le rapport
jamet et d'autre part de revoir notre
action en faveur de la dépendance et son
mode de financement
c'est l'objectif de la réforme voulue
par le président de la république sur la
dépendance dont le débat au niveau
national sera engagé dès le début de
l'année prochaine
nous avons souhaité également par le
volet fiscal de ce projet de loi de
finances rectificative poursuivre notre
action réformatrice
selon plusieurs orientations
d'abord la modernisation de la fiscalité
foncière des entreprises d'autre part
l'encouragement de comportements
favorables à l'environnement la
déclinaison du grenelle et enfin la
simplification des procédures fiscales
et douanières sur la mode ou
modernisations la fiscalité foncière des
entreprises proposant deux dispositifs
le premier porte sur la révision des
valeurs locatives foncières des
entreprises
enfin diront certains et ils ont raison
nous avons préparé cette révision qui
était très attendu maintes fois
repoussée en concertation avec les
associations d'élus et les entreprises
elle permet c'est l'objectif de rétablir
à terme l'équité dans l'impôt foncier
des entreprises à produit constant
nous voudrions conduire une
expérimentation dès l'année prochaine
sur cinq départements les rôles pas de
calais le bas rhin a ri et la haute
vienne en vue d'une généralisation des
travaux pour l'année 2012 et d'une
traduction dans les bases d'imposition
en 2014
les valeurs locatives des entreprises
sont désormais assise sur des valeurs
calculées à partir de loyer réellement
constatés qui seront révisées
automatiquement chaque année la réforme
est limitée à ce stade
oh
aux commerciaux et aux locaux
professionnels des professions libérales
le second dépôt de dispositifs pour la
modernisation de la fiscalité foncière
des entreprises portent sur la
simplification des taxes d'urbanisme à
compter de 2012 de taxes si
naturellement vous adopter cette mesure
seront substitués à 15 des 17
prélèvements existants
d'abord une taxe d'aménagement à
vocation budgétaire qui va reconstituer
l'essentiel du produit des anciennes
taxes avec une part communale une part
départementale dans les taux demeureront
fixé par délibération des collectivités
notre part un versement pour
sous-densité qui vise lui à lutter
contre l'étalement urbain et ce
versement sera instaurée sur
délibération là encore des communes mais
de façon obligatoire dans celles dont
les projets d'équipements sont
importants là encore annoncés dans le
projet de loi grenelle 2 et résultat
d'une longue concertation
cette réforme a reçu le soutien des élus
locaux et des professionnels
le dernier point de cette modernisation
fiscale porte sur des mesures de
financement du grand paris
je les mentionne pour mémoire car j'ai
noté qu'elle avait suscité
l'enthousiasmé de votre assemblée
puisque sans attendre l'examen de ce
collectif vous aviez souhaité les
incorporer dans la loi de finances pour
l'année prochaine le texte adopté en
commission mixte paritaire lundi a
permis de déboucher sur une solution
concernant le financement du logement
social et de l'anru priorité pour bon
nombre de villes locaux à juste titre
tout en maintenant dans le projet de loi
de finances rectificative la création
des recettes fiscales qui doit financer
naturellement les transports en
ile-de-france qui ont bien besoin
d'accompagnement budgétaire pour
améliorer leur fluidité leur efficacité
leur rendu en matière de service public
la deuxième orientation du volet fiscal
de ce projet de loi de finances
rectificative porte sur l'encouragement
des comportements favorables à
l'environnement
en premier lieu le barème du malus
automobile va être durcie à compter de
nous aimons la taxe générale sur les
activités polluantes sur les émissions
d'oxydés d'azoté sera majoré afin de
respecter les prescriptions
communautaire enfin le cadre législatif
permettant la mise en place de l'écotaxe
sur les poids lourds sera adapté aux
exigences opérationnelles révélé à
l'occasion des appels d'offres la
troisième orientation de se coller
budgétaire que j'ai l'honneur de vous
présenter porte sur la simplification
des procédures fiscales et douanières
s'agissant des modalités de déclaration
de l'impôt nous prévoyons la possibilité
de centraliser les montants de tva due
au niveau du groupe
la simplification du calcul du seuil de
chiffre d'affaires pour les auto
entrepreneurs la suppression de
l'exigence de dépôt de la déclaration
d'impôt sur le revenu d'une personne
dans les six mois suivant son décès et
enfin l'extension de la dispense de
cautionnement pour les opérations de
dédouanement à l'entrée du territoire
national il ya également des mesures
techniques qui visent à la
simplification et nous avons souhaité
notamment sur ce point moderniser le
régime fiscal et social des plans
d'épargne-logement il s'agit en fait de
recentrer le pel sur son objectif
premier de financement de l'acquisition
d'un logement le taux de rémunération du
nouveau pel sera fixé annuellement en
fonction des conditions de marché et les
intérêts des nouveaux pel seront soumis
aux contributions sociales au fil de
l'eau et non plus après dix ans d
éléments de trésorerie mais bien
précieux par les temps qui courent par
ailleurs le droit à prime sera
subordonné au fait de contracter un
véritable prêts et cette prime sera
verdi nous avons souhaité ensuite
harmoniser les procédures de
recouvrement forcé pour traduire dans la
législation la fusion entre l'ancienne
direction générale des impôts et
l'ancienne direction générale de la
comptabilité publique au sein de la
nouvelle direction générale des finances
publiques
nous avons voulu enfin mettre en
conformité avec la norme communautaire
certaines dispositions en matière de tva
il s'agit notamment de la suppression du
taux réduit pour les prestations d'être
juridictionnelle et de la fiscalité des
produits du tabac essentiellement la
suppression du prix seuil et la réforme
des mesures encadrant la production des
produits du tabac en france sur ce
dernier point le gouvernement précise
n'est pas question d'accepter la libre
circulation du tabac compte tenu des
enjeux dans le domaine de la santé
publique il notamment dans la lutte
contre le tabagisme
voilà monsieur le président monsieur le
rapporteur général madame le rapporteur
mais là messieurs les sénateurs les
grands axes structurants de ce collectif
budgétaire
évidemment dans la gestion du calendrier
il intervient quelques heures seulement
après une commission mixte paritaire
importante et pour laquelle je tiens
devant la haute assemblée a remercié le
degré d'implication personnelle bien
connu ici et depuis tant et tant
d'années du rapporteur général philippe
marini je veux lui rendre hommage
un hommage sincère individuel mais aussi
eu égard à la dignité de cette fonction
imminente dans un contexte singulier
concernant nos finances publiques exige
est à la fois un échange vertueux entre
le gouvernement et le parlement
je crois qu'il a été en ayant accepté
200 amendements sur les 900 déposé et
puis une représentation nationale au
sein de la commission mixte paritaire
qui a accompagné de manière je crois
très intelligent et très efficace la
volonté d'un objectif partagé intangible
de réduire nos déficits publics merci
encore monsieur rapporteur général
merci monsieur ministre
la parole est à monsieur philippe marini
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
voici venu le quatrième collectif
budgétaire de l'année grâce à ses lois
de finances rectificative
nous avons accompagné le contexte
économique au début de l'année il
s'agissait de sortir de la crise
financière cela nécessitait de prendre
des mesures exceptionnelles pour tâcher
de compenser la perte du produit
intérieur brut potentielle induite par
la crise et ce fut la loi de finances
rectificative permettant le financement
des investissements d'avenir
puis la zone euro a été rattrapée par
d'autres turbulences et ce fut la crise
des dettes souveraines
dès lors on a demandé au parlement de
souscrire aux mesures spécifiques pour
la grèce puis de souscrire à
l'élaboration d'un mécanisme européen
de stabilisation à présent nous allons
pouvoir faire le point coisy définitif
de la situation budgétaire de la france
en cette fin d'année ce point s'inscrit
bien toujours dans le contexte de la
crise de la dette souveraine
certes nous n'avons pas ici de
dispositions spécifiques en faveur de
l'irlande mais la situation de ce pays
est dans tous les esprits
de la même façon que la situation de la
grèce et ses conséquences sur la zone
euro avait occupé une bonne part de nos
débats au premier trimestre de 2010 il
me semble mais chers collègues que nous
sommes fondés à nous poser une première
question
une vraie question les pays de la zone
euro croit-il encore dans la zone euro
cette question est directement lié à la
mise en oeuvre du dispositif que nous
avons approuvé en juin est liée surtout
aux conditions que les pays de la zone
euro vont poser à l'irlande pour prix de
son renflouement
il y a mes chers collègues et je pèse
mes mots
quelque chose d'affolant a constaté d'un
côté la mise sous tutelle économique et
financière d'un état souverain
car lorsque l'on se reporte au plan
irlandais c'est bien de cela qu'il
s'agit
ce pays met entre parenthèses quelque
temps sa pleine indépendance il ya
quelque chose d'affolant a constaté d'un
côté cette mise sous tutelle économique
et financière et de l'autre côté
l'absence de raisonnement à long terme
sur les dommages que provoque
1 de la zone euro l'existence de
systèmes fiscaux non coopératifs
c'est à croire que les états de la zone
euro ne croirai plus vraiment dans
l'avenir de la zone euro qu'ils ont
renoncé dans les faits à l'objectif de
convergence des structures économiques
qu'ils se contentent de passer les
obstacles les uns après les autres
en d'autres termes de bâtir des plans
susceptible seulement de sauver les
intérêts des principaux établissements
financiers créanciers
en tout état de cause monsieur le
ministre il serait utile que l'on nous
dise quand votre collègue chargé de
l'économie sera en mesure d'accorder la
garantie de la france au fonds européen
de stabilité financière quand et comment
sera mis en oeuvre la procédure
d'information des commissions des
finances du parlement prévue à l'article
3 de la loi de finances rectificative de
juin 2010 et permettez moi de le redire
renflouées avec l'argent de la zone euro
un pays à qui on ne demande même pas de
prendre le minimum d'engagement pour
sortir du dumping fiscal
ceci pose une question vraiment
fondamental maintenant en revenant de
notre côté du channel
le déficit de l'état ne peut que
susciter encore beaucoup d'inquiétude
il est supérieur de 27 et demi pour cent
la prévision de la loi de finances
initiale de 2010 de huit et demi pour
cent par un porte à l'exécution de 2009
et nous ne pouvons qu être sensibilisés
nous aussi
à la nécessité d' inspirer confiance aux
analystes et aux marchés à cet égard en
cette période où la sphère budgétaire et
la sphère financière s'interpénètrent on
peut considérer que l' approche
française d'une régulation stricte
constitue pour notre système financier
un vrai atout et protège nos finances
publiques du risque de devoir renflouer
à nouveau ce système financier il est
clair que grâce aux choix que nous avons
fait ensemble monsieur le ministre
parlement et gouvernement notre pays
n'est pas menacé par un scénario à
l'irlandaise maintenant permettez moi
d'en venir à la loi de finances
rectificative en elle-même
par définition une loi de finances
rectificative rectifie des insuffisances
en matière fiscale
c'est un exercice dans la continuité des
années précédentes et nous trouvons ici
beaucoup de choses diverses
alors nous sommes habitués aux
expressions utilisées en la matière
troisième partie de la loi de finances
de l'année à venir session de rattrapage
inventaire à la prévert et c'est vrai
dans ces articles fiscaux on met les
choses importantes à l'accessoire
nous allons traiter du régime fiscal des
chiens de traîneaux de celui des
vendeurs colporteurs de presse
mais nous allons aussi abordé des sujets
significatifs tels que l'aménagement du
régime des sociétés de personnes
la conjugaison à donner aux notions de
transparence et de translucidité fiscal
des sociétés de personnes mais aussi et
le ministre ya fait allusion
nous allons
simplifier et renforcer le régime des
taxes locales d'urbanisme dans le
domaine des dépenses il va falloir
corriger la loi de finances
rectificative rectifie qu'est-ce qu'elle
rectifie elle rectifie les sous dotation
et les dérapages
certes les ouvertures de crédits atteste
monsieur le ministre vous le savez mieux
que nous une hausse significative des
dépenses d'intervention à caractère
social de l'état partiellement mais
partiellement seulement imputable à la
crise et ses ouvertures de crédits
sanctionne la persistance dessous
budgétisation de loi de finances
initiale la loi de finances initiale
quelques exemples cher monsieur le
président les ouvertures en faveur de la
politique de l'emploi 1,3 milliard
d'euros notamment en faveur des contrats
aidés
nous mettons naturellement pas en cause
les mesures prises
simplement nous observons que les
calculs du début d'année était quelque
peu optimistes tant en nombre qu'en mode
de calcul et nous observons en ce
domaine un important dérapage
nous observons aussi en exécution il ne
semble pas vraiment
c'est une litote que l'engagement des
dépenses était effet dans le souci
quotidien et permanent de tenir compte
des disponibilités budgétaires
second exemple l'allocation d'adulte
handicapé plus 319 millions d'euros dont
nos excellents rapporteurs spéciaux ont
de façon récurrente dénoncé le caractère
habituellement sous budgétés troisième
exemple les aides au logement les
dépenses d'hébergement d'urgence plus
275 millions d'euros déjà abondé par
décret davance et une fois encore nous
ne cessons de
dire sans lassitude régulièrement
sous-évaluées en loi de finances
initiale
la fameuse aide médicale d'état
les bourses étudiantes la prise en
charge des demandeurs d'asile autant de
rubriques que nous considérons
habituellement comme insuffisamment doté
en loi de finances initiale
autant de répétition sans surprise dans
la bouche de nos rapporteurs spéciaux
hors dépenses à caractère social nous
observons aussi des ouvertures
permettant de faire face à des pénalités
communautaire dans le domaine agricole
83 millions d'euros en d'autres termes
on a loué des aides hors du droit
communautaire et on est sanctionné pour
sa des dotations destiné à compléter le
financement des opex
là encore c'est une chronique annuelle +
387 millions d'euros
dotation visant à assurer la dette de
l'état vis-à-vis du crédit foncier de
france au titre des primes
d'épargne-logement 83 millions d'euros
et d'ailleurs il n'y a rien à reprocher
à cette écriture qui se conforme aux
recommandations formulées cette année
par notre excellent rapporteur spécial
notre collègue jean pierre fourcade
on peut ajouter à tout cela l'opportune
souplesse consistant à relever le
plafond d'emploi du ministère de
l'éducation nationale pour naturellement
se mettre en situation de le respecter
en exécution si l'on modifie le plafond
on a plus de chances de se tenir deux
dents monsieur le ministre
tout cela vous le savez comme vous savez
que
face aux dépenses que j'ai caractérisée
et qui seront récurrentes
nous avons certes quelques bonnes
surprises du côté des recettes mais ces
bonnes surprises sont de nature
exceptionnelle et non récurrente et je
voudrais en dire quelques mots
nous constatons en sommes heureux une
diminution de la charge de la dette
diminution de 2,2 milliards d'euros par
rapport à la prévision révisée qui nous
a été faite
ceci provient de deux choses le maintien
à un niveau très bas des taux d'intérêt
et d'autre part l'extrême technicité
professionnalisme et ingéniosité de l'
agence france trésor qui grâce en
particulier à la pratique de
l'assimilation et à l'utilisation
opportune du marché a été en mesure de
redéployer un assez grand nombre de
lignes ce qui se traduit par des
économies budgétaires mais ses marges
positives exceptionnel finances
nous le savons des dépenses
d'intervention et de fonctionnement qui
elles n'ont pas le même caractère
exceptionnel nous observons aussi un
effet d'aubaine dont on peut se réjouir
en ce qui concerne les prélèvements sur
recettes cela porte sur 1,2 milliard
d'euros 566 millions d'euros
en ce qui concerne la contribution à
l'union européenne
c'est le mode de calcul qui est un peu
plus favorable et 646 millions d'euros
de réduction du prélèvement sur
ressources en faveur des collectivités
territoriales en raison d'une baisse du
fonds de compensation de la tva
et ce ne sont que des opportunités
momentanée observons aussi nous nous en
réjouissons
une forte hausse des recettes non
fiscales sous l'effet de facteurs
exceptionnels
nous prélevons et c'est tant mieux un
milliard de plus sur la caisse des
dépôts et nous bénéficions de dividende
supplémentaire de grandes sociétés du
secteur public pour 700 millions d'euros
il est tout à fait clair mes chers
collègues que la dépense à l'avenir
devra être mieux calibrée pour que l'on
puisse escompter respecter la
trajectoire des finances publiques
la trajectoire de la consolidation
budgétaire la maîtrise des dépenses
monsieur le ministre c'est la pierre
angulaire de la politique d'ajustement
budgétaire les dérapages des dépenses ne
doivent jamais être pris à la légère
il affecte notre capacité à respecter
nos engagements de soldes et le retour à
l'équilibré primaire ces dérapages
illustre la nécessité d'aller plus loin
que les déclarations de principes en
matière de réformes structurelles et de
multiplier les actions concrètes
permettant de peser sur la dépense et
jeu c'est vrai mon propos je le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues par une brève réflexion sur la
norme de dépense et donc sur la
sincérité la norme de dépense est
exigeante elle doit être appliquée de
façon pérenne et sincère je rappelle que
la norme zéro volume fait l'objet de
quelques raffinements elle continue
d'être l'objectif global mais elle est
complétée par une autre règle selon
laquelle les dépenses hors dette et
pensions doivent être stables en valeur
nous allons donc devoir nous diriger
dans un tunnel entre zéro volume et zéro
valeur leed
et est à présent et c'est une bonne
chose que les économies de constatation
ne puisse plus être recyclés en dépenses
nouvelles
ce que l'on voit s'opérer espérons le
pour la dernière fois dans le présent
collectif le respect des nouvelles
normes le respect du tunnel à compter de
2011 imposera de réelles contraintes
nouvelles
d'ailleurs je me suis livré à de petits
calculs pour vous le montrer
si l'on avait appliqué la loi de
finances initiale pour 2010 les
principes que l'on annonce pour 2011
il aurait fallu arbitrer les dépenses du
budget général 3,9 milliards d'euros au
dessous de ce que le gouvernement nous a
proposé à l'époque
si l'on devait appliquer aujourd'hui à
ce collectif budgétaire
les nouvelles règles zéro volume zéro
valeur les crédits qui nous sont soumis
devrait être inférieure de 5,6 milliards
d'euros au niveau cumulé des ouvertures
pratique en loi de finances initiale et
par les différents collectifs de l'année
hors plan de relance
hors réforme de la taxe professionnelle
et hors financement par le grand entre
une source d'inquiétude permettez moi de
l'évoquer en conclusion monsieur le
ministre c'est la multiplication des
dispositifs de contournement de la norme
de dépense
je sais que vous y êtes particulièrement
vigilant et que le ministre du budget
doit souvent être dans une position un
peu solitaire pour faire respecter de
telle discipline
la nouvelle règle a été conçu pour
imposer des contraintes supplémentaires
aux gestionnaires de crédits
donc il y à une multitude de tentations
par exemple l'article 40 de ce collectif
dont nous allons discuter met en place
pour
apporter notre quote-part cher jacques
gauthier au financement du programme
a400m
un dispositif que je qualifierais de
complexe et ambigu pour financer des
opérations qui à vrai dire relèverait
plus naturellement des crédits de la
mission défense de la même façon
l'article 43 transfert à un compte
d'affectation spéciale donc hors de la
norme de dépense le financement de
parents capital dans les banques
internationales de développement
l'article 33 affecte directement à des
organismes sociaux certaines recettes
afin de rembourser des dettes de l'état
à l'égard de la sécurité sociale ainsi
on évite la case budget général et donc
de se conformer à la norme de dépense
les dispositions de ce projet de loi de
finances rectificative s'ajoute à
d'autres figurant dans la loi de
finances pour 2011 et qui sont de même
nature
elle s'ajoute aussi à l'incidence du
mode de financement des investissements
d'avenir dont l'impact budgétaire a été
entièrement prises en compte en 2010
faut le dire pour le reconnaître alors
même qu'il va majorer de plusieurs
milliards d'euros les dépenses
d'opérateurs de l'état dans les années à
venir
évitant ainsi aux différents ministères
de devoir leur verser des subventions
lors de l'examen du dernier projet de
décret d'avancé
messieurs le ministre commission des
finances a tenu à exprimer son avis
favorable tout en vous faisant part
solennellement de ses inquiétudes
et c'est dans le même esprit que nous
regardons le projet de loi de finances
rectificative
il ya beaucoup de deux points de fuite
en quelque sorte
et face à la menace que cela représente
pour la maîtrise des finances publiques
il convient de se demander si les
dispositifs de provisions ou de
précautions mises en place ces dernières
années pour faire face à des dépenses
imprévues ne sont pas complètement
dépassé c'est une question que nous nous
permettons de poser il convient aussi à
notre sens de rénover les outils de
maîtrise pendant l'exercice budgétaire
des dépenses de l'état c'est l'une des
clés de réussite de la convergence
budgétaire
en d'autres termes nous sommes
demandeurs d'encore plus de contrôle de
gestion dans l'exécution des crédits au
fur et à mesure de l'exercice budgétaire
face à l'importance de l'enjeu l'heure
n'est certainement plus pour personne au
double langage qui consiste à proclamer
la rigueur en évitant de la mettre en
oeuvre leur c'est celle de la cohérence
et c'est bien ainsi monsieur le ministre
que j'ai compris les propos que vient de
tenir le premier ministre françois
fillon hier devant sa majorité
parlementaire engageons donc mes chers
collègues sans complaisance mais de
manière constructive naturellement
l'examen de ce dernier texte financier
de l'année toujours révélateur de nos
ambiguïtés comme de nos espoirs
merci de votre attention
merci sur un porteur général la parole
est à madame catherine morin desailly
rapporteur pour avis de la commission de
la culture de l'éducation et de la
communication monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la commission de la culture de
l'éducation et de la communication s'est
saisie pour avis du projet de loi de
finances rectificative pour 2010 en vue
d'une part de soutenir certaines
dispositions adoptées par nos collègues
députés et d'autre part pour vous
proposer quelques amendements dans le
domaine de la culture
je tiens tout d'abord à attirer votre
attention sur les modalités
d'application aux salles de cinéma de
l'article 17 du plfr sur la réforme de
l'évaluation des valeurs locatives
en effet il serait souhaitable de
prendre en compte les spécificités de
ces locaux à caractère monovalent et à
faible commercialité à cette occasion
cette spécificité a d'ailleurs été prise
en compte je vous le rappelle dans la
loi sur l'équipement numérique des
établissements cinématographiques que
nous avons adoptée en septembre dernier
et qui rend obligatoire le recours aux
usages en vigueur dans l'exploitation
cinématographique pour l'évaluation des
loyers hors au 1er janvier 2012 le
marché locatif des salles de cinéma
n'aura pas encore pu pleinement
bénéficier de ces nouvelles dispositions
protectrices
il conviendrait que les bases locatives
retenu tiennent compte de cette volonté
du législateur d'encadrer les loyers des
salles de cinéma par ailleurs notre
commission soutient les articles adopté
par l'assemblée nationale et relevant de
son champ de compétence je citerais
notamment l'article douce terre qui
aménage les conditions ouvrant droit au
crédit d'impôt relatif à la production
d'oeuvres cinématographiques ou
audiovisuelles en permettant la prise en
compte des différents modes de
rémunération des auteurs ainsi le choix
du type de rémunération des auteurs
les producteurs ne sera plus orienté
artificiellement
je vous rappelle qu'à l'initiative de
notre commission le sénat avait adopté
cette mesure dans le plfr de décembre
mais à l'époque la cmp ne l'avait
finalement pas retenu nous nous
réjouissons donc que nos collègues
députés soient désormais convaincu de
son bien fondé
et nous sommes persuadés que nous
pourront rallier aussi nos collègues les
plus sceptiques de la commission des
finances
l'article 32 bis enfin il modifie le
calcul de la taxe prévue à l'article 302
bis caa sur les régies publicitaires de
télévision afin de prendre en compte la
situation particulière des chaînes
d'information l'article 35
il est temps aux départements
d'outre-mer des dispositifs de soutien
automatique à l'industrie
cinématographique grâce à l'application
à ces territoires de la taxe spéciale
additionnelle à laquelle ils ne sont pas
assujettis aujourd'hui je vous rappelle
que cette taxe alimente le compte de
soutien qui est gérée par le cnc
ainsi les salles des dom pourront
désormais elles aussi bénéficier
notamment d aide à la numérisation
enfin l'article 44 mais en cohérence le
régime de reclassement des maîtres de
conférences des établissements
d'enseignement supérieur publics
relevant du ministre chargé de
l'agriculture sur celui prévu pour les
enseignants chercheurs de l'enseignement
supérieur
un dernier point notre commission vous
proposera d'adopter trois amendements
le premier qui vise à conforter
l'attractivité du crédit d'impôt en
faveur de la production internationale
de films
il s'agit d'une disposition purement
technique sans impact financier
d'aménagement tout simplement de la
procédure d'agrément des oeuvres pour
l'obtention du crédit d'impôt
international
le deuxième amendement tend à relever le
plafond du crédit d'impôt cinéma pour le
porter de 1 à 4 millions d'euros
à l'instar du crédit d'impôt
international des des montants proposés
dans d'autres pays européens
il s'agirait en effet d'éviter la
délocalisation de quelques grosses
productions françaises ce qui est le cas
malheureusement aujourd'hui
enfin un dernier amendement qui vise à
simplifier le circuit de déclaration et
de paiement de la taxe sur les
spectacles d'art dramatique lyrique ou
chorégraphiques et ainsi de diminuer le
coût de sa gestion voilà mes chers
collègues je vous remercie de votre
attention
c'est chaque élève dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à
madame marie-france beaufils pour le
groupe crc spg pour neuf minutes
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
chers collègues
les collectifs de ce1 de fin d'année ont
souvent l'apparence
je vais utiliser un mot plus important
que d'habitude de camion balai qui en
ramassant les dispositions législatives
isolé s'emplissent d'articles
hétéroclite dans le fil conducteur n'est
que leur incidence financière
ce texte n'échappe pas totalement à
cette impression d'autant qu'il est
passé entre le texte initial et celui
que nous allons examiner de 43,74
article et que la discussion peut en
ajouter encore quelques autres
premier constat une légère amélioration
du solde budgétaire global puisque nous
passons de 152 milliards de déficit à
149,7 milliards d'euros
cette amélioration du solde budgétaire
global ne doit rien à la réalité de
l'activité économique et des recettes
pouvant en découler
la croissance attendue au terme de
l'année 2010 risque en effet de rester
inférieure à 2 points et cela impacte
notamment les recettes fiscales de tva
nette et de tei pp l'élan de la
consommation n'est pas assez fort pour
porter très haut ces recettes le seul
pan de la fiscalité ou la progression
des recettes peut s'observer et celui de
la fiscalité du patrimoine
on pourrait comprendre par conséquent la
subite attention exprimée par le
président de la république pour le sujet
mais avant ce débat de 2011 que nous
devrions avoir constatons que les
recettes de l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune
pourtant victime des niches fiscales qui
en affecte le rendement progresse de 253
millions
roh sur les prévisions les plus
optimistes quant aux droits de mutation
à titre onéreux ou gratuit il progresse
de près de 400 millions d'euros
le bon rendement de ces impositions
montre clairement que les valeurs sûres
de l'immobilier se porte fort bien et
que la situation n'est pas plus mauvaise
pour les placements mobiliers la sortie
de la crise s'ils tentaient fut qu elle
fût vrai n'aura pas attendu 2011 pour
quelques propriétaires immobiliers et
quelques contribuables
la situation des comptes publics est
également améliorée par la baisse des
dépenses liées à l'application du droit
fiscal comme les produits de tva brut
sont moins forts nous avons aussi moins
de tva déductible à imputer sur ce
montant la même remarque vaut d'ailleurs
pour l'impôt sur le revenu dont le
rendement a d'ailleurs connu une
inflexion à la baisse on dit qu'elle
serait due à la moindre progression des
rémunérations des salariés
la modération salariale mise en oeuvre
par l'état
imité par le patronat du secteur privé
et la mise en cause du pouvoir d'achat
des retraites créent en effet toutes les
conditions pour faire stagner le produit
de l'impôt sur le revenu d'autres
facteurs interviennent dans la réduction
observée dans cette loi de finances
rectificative du déficit budgétaire
cette année on constate ainsi une
réduction de la contribution de la
france au budget de l'union européenne
réduction imputable à l'ajustement du
prélèvement communautaire au montant des
recettes de tva au temps qu'on
remboursement de versements indus les
années précédentes mais nous avons aussi
une réduction des prélèvements en
direction des collectivités locales avec
une baisse loin d'être faible du fonds
de compensation de la valeur ajoutée qui
explique peut-être d'ailleurs la
facilité avec l'état avec laquelle
l'état accepte en loi de finances
initiale 2011 de retirer le fonds de
compensation de la tva de l' enveloppe
normée
une baisse que l'on peut imputer
l'anticipation des versements intervenus
dans le cadre du plan de relance mais
aussi à la contraction des dépenses
d'équipement des collectivités
territoriales
observez donc dans le rapport qui a été
présenté par par le cf ne pouvons
évidemment nous satisfaire d'une telle
situation puisque la baisse du
prélèvement sur recettes qui en
découlent signifie que l'effort
d'équipement des collectivités s'est
réduit avec lui l'activité économique
elle même singulièrement dans les
domaines du bâtiment et des travaux
publics
ces difficultés proviennent aussi
faut-il le dire des limites de
participation de l'état dans certains
projets structurants répondant aux
besoins collectifs n'étant pas à la
veille de confier au seul montage public
privé les travaux de construction et de
rénovation des stades que notre pays
proposera aux équipes qualifiées pour
l'euro 2016 de football n'engageons pas
l'avenir des projets de nouvelles lignes
tgv en renchérissant via les
partenariats public privé les coûts des
trajets avec le risque d'une perte de la
progression du nombre d'usagers en
pleine contradiction avec le grenelle ou
bien encore il semble aussi que nous ne
soyons qu'au début des difficultés pour
d'autres chantiers de transport
collectif la réalisation par exemple
d'un équipement comme la tangentielle
nord qui doit à terme relier
sartrouville à noisy-le-sec devra se
contenter d'un parcours plus bref entre
epinay sur seine et le bourget les
articles dont nous allons débattre dans
ce texte sur la mise en oeuvre de la
restructuration de la région comme
capitale montre ainsi qu'en l'absence de
consensus sur les objectifs poursuivis
nous sommes aussi sans doute loin d'un
consensus sur les financements mobilisés
la maîtrise des dépenses publiques
pierre angulaire des politiques menées
depuis 2002 trouve d'ailleurs d'autres
illustrations dans le cadre ce collectif
budgétaire et notamment avec les
annulations de crédits désormais rituels
et les ouvertures le plus souvent rendu
inévitable de par l'insuffisance
d'évaluation de certaines dépenses dans
les lois de finances initiale ou
rectificatif d'ores et déjà voté
rapporteur général
il ya un an dire quelques mots il
demeure sur certaines dépenses d'action
sociale sur les aides personnelles au
logement un autre exemple des cas
typiques et récurrent de sous-évaluation
qui appelle des révisions à la hausse et
qui sur le terrain pose de véritables
problèmes
je suis dit outre cette cuisine
budgétaires je ne peux manquer d'évoquer
avec un intérêt particulier la
participation de notre pays aux
errements de la construction européenne
le projet doit nous indique que la
gestion active de la dette a permis de
réduire de 2,2 milliards d'euros le coût
du service de cette dette
en cette année 2010 et s'en félicite
chacun appréciera ce que représente
cette économie au regard des 1500
milliards d'euros de la dette publique
rappelons nous que la raison profonde de
cet allègement du service de la dette
provient aussi de ce que l'on appelle la
qualité de la dette publique française
devant l'aggravation des difficultés de
la grèce ou de l'irlande sans compter et
l'italie ou le portugal et l'espagne
la dette publique française est en effet
devenu plus encore qu'auparavant
un beau pro est un bon produit offrant
sécurité rentabilité à l'investisseur de
fête france trésor a pu adjugé certains
lots de la dette publique à des
conditions plus favorables que prévu
singulièrement sur les titres de court
terme
conséquence positive cependant de ce
dispositif
la part de la dette publique française
contrôlé par les non résidents s'est
encore accru dépassant désormais les 70
% et mettant un peu plus nos politiques
économiques sous la pression des
desiderata des marchés financiers mais
comme les choses sont liées les 2,2
milliards d'euros que nous avons ainsi
retrouvés sur la gestion active de la
dette et la qualité des émissions et des
adjudications peuvent être mis en regard
des 1925 millions que notre pays va
ajouter au concours déjà apportées au
plan grec
un concours que la france apporte pour
sauver les banques de leurs créances
douteuses mais qui va aussi de pair avec
un plan d'austérité imposé par la
commune
aux européennes je me permets d'ailleurs
d'apporter ici même le soutien des
parlementaires de mon groupe aux
salariés aux jeunes et aux retraités
grecs largement mobilisés aujourd'hui
dans le cadre d'une grève générale qui
dit austérité dit ralentissement de
l'activité et nous ne pouvons que nous
étonner de la contagion qui touche à la
matière tous les gouvernements européens
les signes de ce ralentissement sont
déjà perceptibles et la baisse des
investissements locaux en constitue la
première illustration patente la logique
d'austérité demeure très présente de ce
texte comme elle le fut dans le texte de
la loi de finances initiale pour 2011
que nous avons combattu lors de la
discussion budgétaire
cette similitude d'orientation que nous
ne partageons pas nous conduit à avoir
vis-à-vis de ce collectif la même
attitude que face à la loi de finances
pour 2011
il faudrait vraiment de profondes
transformations pendant la discussion
pour que nous puissions le voter merci
chers collègues
la parole est à madame nicole bricq pour
le groupe socialiste pour 20 minutes au
moins
mais pas par les 20 minutes sur le
ministre sarko legs
ah non monsieur le rapporteur général et
l'a donc cette ultime textes budgétaires
de l'année intervient dans un panorama
européen inquiétant le rapporteur
général l'a souligné la crise des
finances publiques mais les états
européens sous contrainte
la crise des finances privées comme en
irlande oblige cette dernière à faire
appel au dispositif de stabilisation
entériné dans la présente loi de
finances rectificative d'avril je crois
et je voudrais souligner que la
commission des finances est toujours en
attente monsieur mise d'une information
des conditions de la mise en oeuvre du
plan daide à l'irlande alors nous il ya
un sommet européen les 16 et 17 décembre
sans doute serons nous plus éclairés
mais je voudrais quand même noté de la
manière la plus courtoise possible que
madame la ministre de l'économie a été
très peu présentes ici au sénat dans la
phase du débat budgétaire qui va de 18
novembre à aujourd'hui
c'est dommage à la demande de la du
président et du rapporteur en séance
d'une information plus complète sur
l'aide à l'irlande
elle a fait une information mais très
laconique je crois qu'il faut vraiment y
revenir à fond c'est le droit des
parlements et je le souhaite notamment
sur les comptes la conditionnalité je
n'en dis pas plus je m'étais exprimé
lors de la loi de finances concernant la
fiscalité notamment alors l'économie
française se remet très lentement du
choc de 2008 la production industrielle
ne devrait retrouver son niveau d'avant
crise qu'en 2013 et l'industrie a payé
le prix fort très fort en termes
d'emplois perdus emplois qu'elle ne
retrouvera pas nos finances publiques
accuseront un déficit de 148 5 milliards
en légère baisse par rapport à la
dernière loi de finances rectificative
qui est très à hauteur de 152 milliards
mais cette baisse est relative car elle
repose sur l'adoption de mesures
discrétionnaires et en réalité elle
cache une révision in his à la baisse de
la prévision initiale du produit des
principales recettes
en effet là comme la la cdc la la caisse
de dépôts et consignations fait l'objet
de prélèvements supplémentaires à
hauteur d'un milliard d'euros dont
l'essentiel porte sur les fonds
d'épargné ce qui est une mauvaise
manière pour qu'elles puissent
reconstituer les fonds propres qui ont
été mises à mal par le choc de 2008
à cela s'ajoute une révision à la hausse
des dividendes versés par la société de
prise de participation de l'état
bref ce surplus de recettes non fiscales
casse la baisse du produit des recettes
fiscales due principalement et là je
veux insister un coût des dépenses
fiscales plus élevées que prévu grevant
l'impôt sur le revenu le surcoût
s'établit à 1,8 milliard c'est énorme et
les rentrées d'impôt sur les sociétés ne
sont pas celle espérée
le produit de la tva est revue à la
baisse mais il est vrai et l'âge le
rapporteur général du budget l'a
souligné en commission que cette baisse
de la tva c'est un paradoxe est
compensée par les imposition du
patrimoine et donc je veux dire à tout
le monde que heureusement que nous avons
les revenus du patrimoine pour compenser
la baisse de la tva et je le souligne au
moment où il est question de revoir la
fiscalité du patrimoine le gouvernement
fera bien d'y regarder à deux fois
vous avez dit monsieur le rapporteur
général en commission que c'étaient les
seuls revenus du patrimoine qui était
dynamique je reprends votre terme
donc il faudra bien y réfléchir l'année
prochaine les économies sur la charge de
la dette de 2,2 milliards contribuent
elles aussi à l'amélioration du solde
mais nous le savons tous mes chers
collègues cela ne durera pas et en 2013
la france devrait être en europe
le premier émetteur de dette et tout le
monde s'attend à une remontée des taux
les recettes donc j'en conclus que les
recettes de l'état ne sont pas protégés
et surtout sap a été soulignée ça je
veux le faire elles n'ont pas
l'élasticité espérait je rappelle que la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques mis sur une croissance à 2% ce
qui est exagérément optimistes nous
l'avons dit et redit et ajuste les
recettes à cette hypothèse
et je vienne rappeler qu'en 2010 malgré
une croissance attendue de 1,6 1,7 à la
fin de l'année il n'y a pas eu le
surcroît des recettes affiché en loi de
finances initiale
tout cela signifie clairement que la
trajectoire transmise à bruxelles
d'ores et déjà ne sera pas respectée dès
et si nous nous le voyons les
parlementaires je pense que les marchés
financiers
le voit aussi bien que nous les
analystes décortique non seulement les
lois de finances initiale mais
l'exécution de ces lois de finances
alors évidemment la raison en est simple
un système fiscal inchangé et moi je le
qualifie de passoire grever
d'exonération je reviens pas sur la
baisse de la tva dans la restauration 3
milliards mais multiple et nombreuses
les niches et depuis une dizaine
d'années qui ne font que galoper il faut
pas s'étonner de du fait que les
recettes et bien même avec un surcroît
de croissance sont quand même beaucoup
plus faibles que celles qui étaient
inscrits en loi de finances initiale
alors ou alors ça veut dire que la loi
de finances initiale n'était pas sincère
ce qui est possible aussi les deux sont
possibles et les dépenses quant à elle
ça a été soulignée sont sous-évaluées
j'en veux pour preuve je le rappelle
puisqu'on l'a dénoncé tous en loi de
finances initiale
le décret d'avant ce que le gouvernement
a demandé au parlement afin d'ouvrir les
crédits de personnel au bénéfice de huit
ministères à hauteur de près d'un
milliard d'euros
alors cela veut dire aussi il faut
traduire cela pour ceux qui liront les
débats et ceux qui qui peuvent les
écouter ça ça relève un fait c'est que
la mesure claironné de d'économies
attendues sur la suppression d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux qui part à la
retraite qui devait rapporter 500
millions par an eh bien elle ne l'est
rapportent pas pour la bonne raison
qu'ils ne partent plus en retraite et le
syndrome de la réforme des retraites va
peser de plus en plus et que les mesures
de compensation qui avait été négociée
légitimement avec les
organisations syndicales et bien elles
continuent à peser
donc les économies de 500 millions il
faut faire voilà il faut considérer que
si elle arrive à rendre 100 millions et
en contrepartie on a une perte de
service public que ce soit au niveau
local comme au niveau national alors sa
nuit aussi à la crédibilité de la
trajectoire triennal qui a été présenté
à bruxelles
enfin et ça c'est quand même important
pour nous c'est nateur les travaux de
l'assemblée nous ont révélé que le coût
de la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle pourrait être du double
que celui qui avait été estimé par le
gouvernement
cela relativise la déclaration récente
de madame parisot présidente du medef
qui considèrent elles dénoncent comme
considérable ce sont ses termes
en 2011 les prélèvements obligatoires
sur les entreprises
et je pense que madame parisot ne sait
pas compter
parce que si on regarde les niches sur
l'impôt sur les sociétés les le
le souffle soit disant apporter aux
entreprises par la disparition de la
taxe professionnelle le fait que la
nouvelle cotisation sur la valeur
ajoutée comme la contribution foncière
dès leur naissance ont mis t elle aussi
d'exonération n'a rien réformer sur le
fond et bien ça relativise complètement
les déclarations de la présidente du
medef
d'autant que le rapporteur général de
l'assemblée a qualifié la la suppression
de la taxe professionnelle d'allègement
historique
ce sont ses termes dans son rapport
écrit la pression fiscale des
entreprises
elle est comparable ça je le dis pour
qu'eux-mêmes parisot l'entendent
même si ma voix porte peu au delà de cet
hémicycle mais vous le répèterai et bien
la baisse de la taxe professionnelle
historiques comme la qualifie notre
collègue carrese elle est comparable à
celle des baisses cumulées de l'impôt
sur les sociétés adopté entre 2000 et
vous pouvez vous que vous conférer à son
rapport écrit alors j'en finis avec les
considérations générales et il faut
souligner que l'examen de trois lois de
finances en l'espace de deux mois à
peine prive le parlement du temps
d'examen nécessaire et du recul pour
apprécier vraiment l'évolution entre
prévisions exécution quand il faut
jongler entre loi de finances initiale
loi de finances rectificative comme ça a
été le cas avec l'article 15 relatif au
financement du grand paris et j'en viens
donc à la loi de finances rectificative
elle même elle est traditionnellement un
véhicule balle et nous avons droit comme
à l'habitude à de multiples dispositions
mais aussi à 3 réforme d'importance
qu'ils auraient dû faire l'objet de
projets de loi spécifique
la réforme des sociétés de personnes le
plan d'épargne-logement et la refonte
des taxes d'urbanisme et notamment la
dernière puisqu'on passe de 6 taxe à
deux taxes
elle impacte directement les
collectivités locales elle aurait mérité
au sénat de faire l'objet d'un projet de
loi spécifique
parce que franchement nous n'avons pas
le temps
d'y regarder de plus près donc je
consacrerai les minutes qui me reste à
quelques développements concernant les
collectivités locales
le premier développement concerne
précisément cet article 15 le
financement du grand paris que le
rapporteur général a réservé à demain
matin et nous le comprenons dans la
mesure où il doit tenir compte du
compromis mauvais compromis mais on en
reparlera à mes yeux du mauvais
compromis non
oui mais il est pas bon celui-là réalisé
par la majorité en cmt sur la loi de
finances pour 2011
mais justement je voudrais quand même
rappeler à propos du grand paris les
engagements et du gouvernement et du
président de la république parce que
cette loi de finances rectificative
dans son article 15 relativise
complètement les déclarations qui
avaient été faites
la société du grand paris devait être
doté de 4 milliards gagés sur le
remboursement des prêts consentis aux
constructeurs automobiles déjà il ne
rembourser que 2 milliards mais ils
peuvent encore le faire
l'échéance n'est pas finie et on nous
explique ici
le gouvernement explique que cette
dotation sera mobilisée par l'état au
fur et à mesure du projet et comme la
société du grand paris
aux termes de la loi d'orientation et de
programmation des finances publiques ne
pourra pas emprunter au delà d'un an
cela veut dire que elle n'aura ni le
loisir d'emprunter au delà d'un an
ni date doté par l'état avant trois ans
on est donc très loin de l'annnonce du
président de la république le 29 avril
de cette année c'est pas si vieux qui
prévoyait le début des travaux pour 2012
lors du débat sur cette loi grand paris
nous n'avons pas arrêté nouveau position
de dire que ce projet était irréaliste
et fumeux alors on ne renie rien de ce
qu'on a dit on verra ce qu'il en sera
à l'issue des deux débats publics
engagés sur le projet du conseil
régional d'île de france et sur le
projet de l'état n'en serions pas
l'avenir il peut là aussi y avoir des
bons compromis sur le financement mais
je relève que les recettes fiscales qui
était prévu par la mission carrese était
dans une première phase clairement
affecté aux priorités régionales
l'article 16 modifie le zonage sur
lequel repose le versement transport en
ile de france
monsieur le ministre la proposition de
l'assemblée nationale nous apparaît bien
meilleure que celle initiale du
gouvernement mais avec un défaut c'est
que contrairement à la mission carrese
aucune augmentation des taux n'est prévu
l'article 16 bis augmente le versement
transport pour les communes et epc i
dont la population est comprise entre 50
milles et 100000 habitants c'est la
version assemblée nationale le
gouvernement ne s'y est pas opposé nous
nous en félicitons car c'est
l'amendement que nous avions défendu au
nom de notre collègue notamment riez
président du gart en loi de finances
initiale qui avait été rejetée ici mais
s'il est accepté tant mieux nous
souhaitons donc que cette version soit
adoptée il est en effet fondamental de
trouver des recettes pour financer les
transports urbains la mission caresse de
2009 avaient le mérite d'en recenser
pour l'ile-de-france certains
financements sont sollicités dans ce
texte et je devrai rappelé qu'il avait
fait aussi appel à l'écotaxe poids
lourds et l'article 20 de ce projet de
loi de finances rectificative se
contente d'assurer la sécurité juridique
du dispositif adopté dans la loi du 3
août 2009
mais en revanche monsieur le ministre sa
mise en oeuvre demeure flou
les professionnels parlent de 2013
le l'ancien ministre des transports
avait parlé
2 2012 et je vois que le projet de loi
de finances rectificatif fait référence
à 2012 mais quelle est la vérité ne le
savons pas vrai quand même rappeler que
l'écotaxe en allemagne qui avait qui
avait fait l'objet de mises en oeuvre
assez difficile eh bien quand vous
regardez le produit de cette écotaxe en
2009 elle a été de 4 milliards 400
millions ce qui n'est pas rien et ce qui
permet du reste à l'allemagne de rénover
son réseau routier qui ne l'avait pas
été depuis la guerre alors il est vrai
que la fourchette de la taxe allemande
est conséquente même si la nôtre ne
devrait rapporter qu'un milliard c'est
ce qui est prévu dans les estimations il
serait bien utile au transport urbain en
ile de france comme ailleurs et je
voudrais que ce flou soit levé sur la
date d'application je sais bien que 2012
est une année délicate puisque nous
avons une élection cardinal mais il
faudra bien lever le mystère sur cette
taxe poids lourds et je crois que nos
finances ne peuvent pas s'en priver
surtout pour aider les transports
urbains enfin l'article 34 propose la
création d'un fonds exceptionnel de
soutien de 75 millions d'euros aux
départements en difficulté et une
ouverture de crédit supplémentaire de 75
millions
cette solution ponctuelle n'est
évidemment pas la hauteur des besoins
des départements
nous en sommes plusieurs fois expliqué
ici et encore tout dernièrement lors de
l'examen de notre proposition de loi le
9 décembre
vu la modicité des sommes en jeu du fn
et ça nous souhaitons que ces sommes
soient ciblées sur les départements les
plus en difficulté et concernant les
subventions exceptionnelles qui seraient
liées à la signature d'une convention
entre état et département les
contreparties qui seraient exigées par
l'état pourraient s'apparenter à la mise
sous tutelle ce qui n'est pas acceptable
et ce qui ne sera pas acceptée par les
départements donc on repose sur un
financement de 75 millions alors que on
sait qu'il s'agit de plusieurs milliards
en définitive le gouvernement n'a pas
mis à profit le temps
pour chercher à compenser dans les
comptes de l'état le coût de la
suppression de la taxe professionnelle
il n'a pas davantage cherché à corriger
l'injustice de la fiscalité locale
reposant sur les ménages il ne se dote
pas des moyens de sortir la tête de
l'eau des conseils généraux en
difficulté la fille sage pour conclure
monsieur le président l'affichage de la
loi de finances pour 2010 a vécu le
gouvernement a cherché à gagner du temps
est bien celui ci le rattrapera merci
chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur françois
fortassin pour le groupe
rds pour 8 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'adoption du projet de loi de finances
pour 2011 n'est pas encore achevée qu'il
nous faut examiner le collectif
budgétaire
nous sommes habitués à cet exercice qui
a quand même quelque chose d'assez de
relativement insolite
certains mauvais esprits diront qu'il
s'agit plutôt une session de rattrapage
qui ne veut pas dire son nom et d'autres
préféreront noir dans ce texte
l'ultime occasion pour l'amener de
tenter de redresser quelque peu la barre
des déficits qui deviennent à bissau il
ya aussi des effets relativement peu
pervers en ce qui concerne la verte
public
voilà un texte technique relativement en
fourreau tout le quatrième du nom au
cours de l'année 2010 et qui prévoit
diverses dispositions d'ordre économique
et financier au demeurant on peut
observer que les projets de loi de
finances rectificative se succèdent sans
jamais prendre à bras le corps les
véritables difficultés cercle mais il
est évident que le vrai problème c'est
celui qui est ressentie par nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens ont le
sentiment que ce rabot fiscal
le joli terme qui a été inventé dans
certains cas est devenu une sorte de
lime à ongles et qu'il n'a pas fait
produit les effets escomptés en réalité
mais je vais vous en faire immédiatement
une loi de finances elle doit comme son
nom l'indiqué essayer d'assainir les
finances mais elle doit avant tout
partir de certains principes
vous ne ferez pas croire à nos
concitoyens que votre volonté de ne pas
supprimer le bouclier fiscal est une
bonne chose
c'est le symbole de l'inéquité c'est le
symbole d'injustice
et ce sont ceux qui souffrent qui ont
des difficultés sur le plan financier
qui ont le sentiment que l'on fait des
cadeaux à ceux de nos concitoyens qui
sont relativement aisées et si on avait
mis en place le bouclier fiscal si on
avait mis en place l'abrogation du
bouclier fiscal
l'abrogation du bouclier fiscal
il est évident que ceux qui en
bénéficient n'aurait pas vu de façon
très sensible
leur niveau de vie baisser pas plus que
leur pouvoir m'asseoir et cela tant que
vous ne voudrez pas prendre en compte
ces données
vous ferez du mauvais replâtrage de la
même façon on a eu l'occasion de vous
dire que nos concitoyennes n'accepte pas
que les revenus du travail soient
frappés fiscalement beaucoup plus que
les revenus du capital et du patrimoine
c'est quelque chose que la plupart de
nos concitoyennes ne conçoivent pas
résultat il y à une perte de confiance
perte de confiance des élus politiques
pertes aux consciences et du
gouvernement et à partir de là comment
vous c'est une gageur de vouloir
redresser un pays s'il n'y a pas cette
notion de confiance et c'est ça le mot
me semble-t-il
le domaine essentiel que nous vous
aurions pu au travers de cette loi
rectificative corriger sur le plan
technique j'ai eu l'occasion de vous le
dire on peut trouver de bons arguments
sauf que c'est bon argument ne résiste
pas à une analyse politique et c'est la
raison pour laquelle les déficits vont
continuer malheureusement à s'accroître
et nous au niveau du rdse nous le
pouvons vous incitez qu'à donner un
véritable coup de barre en direction de
plus d'équité de plus d'égalité de façon
à restaurer véritablement la confiance
et les finances de ce pays
faute de quoi et bien nous aurons
toujours la possibilité de dire que la
phrase se porte un peu moins mal que
l'irlande l'espagne la grèce ou le
portugal mais ce n'est pas avec ce type
d'affirmation que l'on permettra à notre
pays de sortir de la crise certes la
crise est là mais elle est responsable
pour un tiers de nos difficultés
financières pour le reste il y a des
choses plus profondes que le
gouvernement et sa majorité n'ont pas
voulu aborder en profondeur et c'est la
raison pour laquelle est bien la
majorité du groupe du rrs que votera
contre ce projet de loi de finances
rectificative
merci chaque collègue la parole et à
monsieur adrien gouteyron pour le groupe
ump pour dix minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur général
mesdames et messieurs mes chers
collègues nous examinons donc
aujourd'hui cela a été rappelé le
quatrième collectif budgétaire de
l'année 2010 et le contexte économique
et financier international
on le sait nous oblige à beaucoup de
pragmatisme et à une grande réactivité
la croissance est de retour mais et les
fragiles et un faible niveau est
l'exemple de l'irlande mais aussi de
l'espagne du portugal ne manque pas
qu'elles pointent la nécessité
d'assainir nos finances publiques est
devenue prégnante
nous devons cheminer sur la route de
crête qui entre le soutien de la
croissance et de la commune de la
consommation de l'emploi est de sur
l'autre versant la nécessité de réduire
notre déficit public et à terme notre
endettement
le collectif budgétaire de fin d'année
se situe entre le plan de relance en
mode gestion de crise et le rabot des
niches fiscales en mode sortie de crise
c'est tout dire
la commission mixte paritaire sur le
projet de loi de finances pour 2011
s'est réuni avant-hier a été
l'illustration de la difficulté de
parvenir à cet équilibre entre des
logiques économiques et financières
parfois contradictoires la succession
des collectifs budgétaires entraînent un
affinement de nos prévisions et le
montant du déficit budgétaire arrêté
dans la présente loi de finances
rectificative et globalement conformes
aux dernières prévisions est même en
légère amélioration puisque il célébra
comme le rapporteur général nous l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure en exécution 2010
à 149,7 milliards d'euros au lieu de 152
milliards d'euros prévus dans la
dernière loi de finances rectificative
mais si on regarde l'équipe
l'écart avec la prévision de la loi de
finances
initiale pour 2010 qui était de 117
milliards 2004 cet écart est bien plus
important mais cela tient compte des
investissements d'avenir liés au grand
emprunt et des prêts consacré à la grèce
par ailleurs si le collectif confirment
le respect de la norme de dépense zéro
volume objectifs fixés par l'évolution
des dépenses de l'état en 2010 ce
respect de la norme est dû aussi un
double effet d'aubaine sur les
prélèvements sur recettes et la charge
de la dette et fait très bien décrit par
notre rapporteur général
ce collectif nous montre donc que la
situation demeure fragile et bien
entendu nous devons surveiller
l'évolution des taux auquel nous
empruntons nous profitons en quelque
sorte pour le moment but détournant des
investisseurs des obligations
irlandaises ou dans une moindre mesure
espagnole italienne ou portugaises et
mais nous ne sommes pas à l'abri d'une
remontée des taux souvenons-nous ans
pour preuve les taux des crédits
immobiliers qui remonte en cette fin
d'année en france pour la première fois
depuis deux ans et notant qu'en
allemagne
l'émetteur on le sait les plus solides
de la zone euro l'allemagne donc est à
son tour touchée par la crise non pas
par la crise de la dette souveraine mais
elle voit remonter pour la première fois
depuis de très longues années de très
longs mois le taux de ses emprunts à dix
ans et cette remontée les situe au delà
de la barre des 3% alors que ces mêmes
taux avait enregistré un record
historique à la baisse début novembre à
2,40 pour cent n'oublions pas que nous
sommes tributaires des évolutions du
marché obligataire américain
face à cette vue la volatilité ambiante
les réformes doivent être solides elles
peuvent être pérenne la réforme des
retraites en 2010 a été de ce point de
vue salutaire
le chantier de la dépendance a d'ores et
déjà été annoncées et bien entendu nous
soutiendrons les projets de réforme
il s'agit d'un chantier
difficile dans lequel nous devons nous
engager avec détermination la réforme de
la dépendance en effet doit soulager les
finances de nos départements
en attendant même si le montant demeure
faible compte tenu de l'ampleur du
problème
la mise en place d'un fonds exceptionnel
de soutien en faveur des départements
proposé dans le présent collectif il est
doté de 150 millions d'euros va
néanmoins dans le bon sens tout à
l'heure le ministre a présenté ce fonds
il s'adressera aux départements en
difficulté prévient proviendra pour
moitié de crédits du programme concours
spécifique et administrations répartis
entre les départements suivants leur
situation furent note financière et pour
l'autre moitié d'un prélèvement sur les
réserves de la caisse nationale de
solidarité pour l'autonomie
ces derniers 75 millions d'euros sont
répartis entre les départements dont la
proportion d'habitants de plus de 75 ans
est supérieure à la moyenne nationale en
fonction du revenu disponible des
personnes âgées des départements
concernés et de leur potentiel fiscal
la pondération de ces croix de ces trois
critères sera précisé par décret
monsieur le ministre mais je
souhaiterais d'ores et déjà que vous
puissiez nous dire qu'elles seront
quelques indications du moins sur les
futures modalités de cette répartition
si du moins elles sont déjà définis je
me félicite par ailleurs au nom du goût
de mon groupe de la révision tant
attendu des valeurs locatives foncières
leur ai évoqué tout à l'heure même si
elle ne concerne pour le moment que les
locaux professionnels danse un
département et de manière évidemment
expérimental mais le mouvement est lancé
et il devrait aboutir à une entrée en
vigueur en 2014 nous attendons cela
depuis longtemps
concernant les collectivités
territoriales je rappelle que nous avons
décidé de les associer en 2009 au plan
de relance par le remboursement anticipé
du fonds de compensation de la tva
ainsi les collectivités qui s'engageait
auprès de l'état accroît tout à
maintenir leurs investissements par
rapport aux quatre années précédentes
pouvaient en bénéficier
cette mesure on le sait avait rencontré
un vif succès auprès des collectives
qui furent nombreuses à s'engager dans
le plan de relance contribuant ainsi à
soutenir l'activité économique pendant
la crise ce sont au total près de ma
demi collectivités territoriales qui en
souscrit cet engagement sur un montant
d'investissement de 57 milliards d'euros
l'an dernier le parlement avait souhaité
un assouplissement de la mesure du fait
de difficultés notamment pour les
petites communes a mandaté toutes les
dépenses relatives aux investissements
concernés il avait été ainsi décidé en
loi de finances que les restes à
réaliser serait prise en compte en plus
des dépenses mandaté afin d'évaluer
l'engagement des collectivités
mon collègue charles guené présentera un
amendement permettant l'application de
cet assouplissement aux collectivités
locales engagées dans le plan de relance
en 2010 notre le monde sera jeunes
indique tout de suite très favorable à
cette mesure en faveur de notre de nos
collectivités
nous tiendrons également la très
pertinente réforme des taxes d'urbanisme
quant à la réforme des sociétés de
personnes nous soutiendrons la position
de la commission des finances du sénat
qui a jugé comme l'assemblée nationale
que les conditions d'examen quelques peu
précipité du collectif de fin d'année ne
sont pas propices à l'élaboration d'une
analyse pertinente et à une réforme
aussi complexe et propose donc
d'attendre le collectif de juin prochain
sur la réforme de la fiscalité du
patrimoine pour prendre une décision
la majorité monsieur venus du groupe ump
estime également qu'il convient de
mettre en conformité en conformité avec
le droit communautaire les règles
françaises en matière de détention et de
circulation des produits de tabac mais
j'ai bien noté ce que vous avez dit tout
à l'heure dans votre intervention
dans ces conditions et pour que toutes
les raisons que j'ai évoquées
notre groupe votera le présent projet de
loi de finances rectificative merci
chers collègues
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
président la commission des finances le
rapporteur général
le rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs quelques éléments en
complément de mon propos liminaires et
qui permettent d'apporter des éclairages
complémentaires sur les interventions
des uns des autres je voudrais d'abord
sur l'irlande monsieur rapporteur
général puisque vous avez posé la
question des modalités de soutien à
l'irlande et notamment de la garantie de
l'état rappeler que c'est un montant
entre 4 et 5 milliards uniquement sur
les emprunts qui seront émis par le
fonds européen de stabilité financière
soit 17,7 milliards sur les 85 milliards
le fonds devrait mettre courant janvier
comme vous le savez et avant cette
émission les états seront invités à
engager leurs garanties via un titre
garantie qui sera remis aux
investisseurs et c'est à ce moment que
la ministre de l'économie christine
lagarde apportera au parlement toutes
les informations conformément à ce qui
est prévu par la troisième loi de
finances rectificative pour 2010 et que
nous avions examiné
juste avant l'été je rappelle que le
plan en faveur de l'irlande s'inscrit
dans un plan d'ajustement très rigoureux
qui a préparé en toute indépendance par
la commission européenne le fmi en lien
avec la bce tous les acteurs sont sur le
bateau c'est loin d'être un chèque en
blanc
comme vous le savez on ne peut pas dire
qu'aucun effet aucune contrepartie n'a
été demandé à l'irlande quand on voit la
puissance du plan d'austérité on peut le
qualifier comme tels et caen et quand on
vois l'addition des interrogations
susceptibles de nourrir y compris le
départ d'une partie de la jeunesse
irlandaise on mesure mieux aussi la
hauteur du courage de l'actuel
gouvernement irlandais même si
naturellement son son destin est lié à
la situation budgétaire de son pays mais
on ne peut que saluer le courage et la
volonté politique pour sauver l'irlande
de mettre en place des dispositifs d'une
rigueur extrême
si ce n'est pas une contrepartie je ne
sais pas ce que je fais alors en
revanche de la question sur l'évolution
de la fiscalité notamment de la
fiscalité des entreprises
je crois qu'il faut y aller pas à pas
concernant mr longue étape par étape
nous soutenons ce plan de rigueur je
n'envoie pas de plus difficile sur la
baisse des salaires des fonctionnaires
sur la suppression des postes sur sur
l'évolution des dépenses de protection
sociale sur la hausse de la tva
je pourrais vous dire que je comprends
tout ce que vous dites je ne pourrais
pas vous dire en responsabilité
aujourd'hui que je les partage dont
l'officialisation de ces demandes
je veux répondre également sur
rapporteur général brièvement sur les
ouvertures de crédit et le point que
vous avez mis en avant concernant les
soupes budgétisation en mettant en avant
deux idées principales nous financions
en 2010 un dépassement de dépenses qui
est très largement exceptionnel et kelly
en grande partie à la situation
économique qui n'est pas illogique de
mettre en regard une ressource elle
aussi ponctuel sur les charges de la
dette notamment
et ceci ne remet pas en cause la
budgétisation sincère que nous avons
effectués pour le plf 2011
s'agissant des dépenses d'intervention
nous présentons dans ce collectif plus
de 3 milliards d'euros d'ouverture de
crédit qui sont évidemment engager
totalement par des annulations à due
concurrence
nous respectons ainsi la norme de
dépense dans un contexte difficile je
vous remercie d'avoir évoqué ces
ouvertures sont exceptionnelles et
conjoncturelles près d'un milliard 4 sur
le budget de l'emploi parce qu'il était
indispensable de soutenir l'activité et
l'emploi les plus fragiles sur la
mission solidarité en raison évidemment
des difficultés plus grandes de retour à
l'emploi des personnes handicapées qui
pèsent sur la dépense h notamment et sur
l'hébergement d'urgence ou les aides au
logement qui là encore sont sensibles à
la situation économique
votre qualité éminente demain vous
permet de mieux aborder encore cette
dimension de politique de proximité donc
d'accompagnement à travers des fruits
budgétaire d'irrigation de politique de
proximité qui impactent directement à
l'égard des publics les plus fragiles en
face de ses dépassements très largement
exceptionnelle nous mettons au regard
une moindre dépense elle aussi ponctuel
sur la charge de la dette
vous l'avez souligné et dans une moindre
mesure sur les prélèvements en faveur
des collectivités locales et de l'union
européenne c'est donc 2
autre point de vue un schéma équilibré
qui permet de faire face à des dépenses
pour l'essentiel obligatoire sans que
cela remette en cause nos engagements de
maîtrise des dépenses concernant le
caractère structurel ou reconductible de
ces dépassements et leur impact sur
l'année prochaine je veux vous rassurer
les dépassements dont nous parlons en
2010 ne sont pas ceux des surprises pour
une très grande majorité elles ont été
anticipées
c'est logique de dépassement est intégré
dans le plf 2011
nous ne cachons rien sous le tapis tout
est sur la table tout est transparent et
tout cela a été pris en compte dans la
construction budgétaire quelques
exemples rapide le budget de l'emploi
sur lequel nous faisons entre 1 milliard
et un milliard et demi d'économies
l'année prochaine reste stable en valeur
quelle en est la raison tout simplement
parce que tenu compte de l'impact en
2011 des dérapages constatés en 2010 la
même question d'ailleurs avait été
formulée à l'assemblée sous la même
forme et avec les mêmes termes
c'est évidemment la même réponse ce qui
montre que la question est logique mais
il me semble que la réponse est
également solide nous faisons moins de
contrats aidés l'année prochaine car la
situation économique s'améliore or la
dotation pour les contrats aidés
augmente elle de 400 millions d'euros en
la dotation pour la chaire évalué de
près de 700 millions d'euros incluant
pour moitié bien sûr le coût de la
revalorisation annuelle et la
progression anticipée des bénéficiaires
mais surtout pour l'autre moitié c'est
une vraie remise à niveau de la dotation
qui tire les conséquences des ouvertures
d ouverture qui sont demandées dans le
cadre du présent collectif budgétaire
je précise d'ailleurs sur ce point qu'un
arbitrage était rendu en ce sens par le
président de la république lui même qui
vise à tenir l'engagement d'augmentation
hauteur de 25% d'âge à l'échelle de
cette législature et de la même façon
nous tenons compte du dépassement lié
aux moindres départs en retraite 2009 et
2010 dans la budgétisation des crédits
des personnels des différents ministères
vous avez souligné cher philippe marini
le caractère plus contraignant ou plus
vertueux de la norme de dépense zéro
valeur que l'état s'est fixé à compter
de 2011
je remercie évidemment adrien gouteyron
également d'avoir souligné que nous
respections la norme
cette année et nous respecterons
naturellement celle plus contraignantes
de l'année prochaine en zéro valeur
voilà donc pour cette séance consacrée à
l'examen du projet de loi de finances
rectificative pour 2010 tout de suite
preuve par trois michel grossiord reçoit
rachida dati l'ex garde des sceaux et
bien sûr vous pouvez toujours retrouver
toutes les séances sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée sur notre chaîne